hi I'm jasmine hey I'm Chris reinecker
hi I'm Lee a and I'm Kelsey peach again
and today we're gonna be taste testing
exotic fruit my personal relationship
with fruit is this strong one fruit and
I go way back I love fruit what's your
favorite peach oh yes I love peaches and
pineapple I always love a raspberry
raspberry is in my opinion the perfect
fruit raspberry if you give me a bowl of
raspberries they're gone game over
the things that I don't like I don't
like cantaloupe and I don't like melon
unless unique fruit yeah I think that's
one that I've had yeah yeah I feel like
all the most unique fruits that I've had
I've never known what they were while I
was eating it I feel like star fruit is
the most exotic but maybe it's just cuz
the name sounds fun
let's try the first fruit I'm nervous I
have no idea what these are I don't know
what they are doing there's a seed in it
in the middle you're ruining this for me
I'm trying to discover it this looks
like a sea anenome what are those sea
urchins are no fridge ads it's at
Lumberton yes Wow
yeah but it's creepy it is so creepy it
looks like it moves touch it the world
is so exciting should right just like
cutting yeah all right I'm really like
this thing's alive whoa it's a heart
it's the it's like a grape inside I
forgot there's a hat now it has a hat
Wow look you match it's almost like a
lychee does this work for you in what
way like is it cool you're gonna be the
official taste session that I'm gonna
taste it up for you okay
my fruit I don't know I own it it's not
what this video is about mm-hmm Wow this
texture not my friend
text your grape flex it's like skin
grape taste mild mild flavor sweet
sweetness is nice nice sweetness it's
not bad it's very light it's almost
taste like a pear mm-hmm I'm confused a
skin grape is a good way to describe it
it's it's slimy it's fun
this experience is fun but I don't know
if the taste is like worth it it's just
fine it's just really really light it's
got like a different sweetness grape has
a little bit of a little bit more like
that's a little bit more Tang a little
not a time I think if I had kids I would
buy it and be like let's play I think
you're eating this for the game
you're not eating this for like the
flavor of it you're eating this cause
it's fun
I disagree like you like the flavor I
wouldn't get this something grocery
store no good get it great because
they're fun not cuz they're good alright
let's try the next one
I'm scared Oh excited I do not know what
it is wait dragon fruit hahahaha do you
know what that is it's this dragon fruit
yay oh I'm nailing this I've only seen
the insides of this I thought Drago for
it was
I realized that I'm not well-versed in
fruit so I thought I was a fruit boy
maybe I'm not a boy it's the one you
were talking about yeah yeah it's
beautiful
this is pretty so pretty yeah like now I
recognize this but I didn't recognize
this squash looking thing from the
outside
I've eaten one of these but it was pink
it wasn't yeah I feel like I've never
had it myself it's always in a smoothie
yeah oh yeah I love crazy I actually
didn't expect to have my mind blown this
much it's so nice
but with very watermelon hmm but not as
like crunch as watermelon it's a more
soft it's like mild are not hard Kiwi
what I like about it I'm like a textures
like person and I like that this is like
this seeds provide a really nice crunch
moment we're like conch moment crunch
moment brought to you by dragon fruit is
a dope name can we talk about that it's
not it's more mild than you would expect
from a thing that is named dragon fruit
oh I would buy this for sure me too I
don't think I've ever even seen this in
a grocery store there's only one more
is this a Dragon's egg this one's cool I
don't know if I know this one Hey I know
- I don't
Samoa it looks almost like an apple pear
if it was a dragon birthday what does it
taste like
I believe it kind of tastes it like pear
yeah is cherimoya
would you like to kind of Spanish for
dragon fruit yeah I'm one up again yeah
relax with your knife I don't know how
to cut it though it's very hard it's
just like a reptile Apple if an apple is
a reptile okay I don't want to eat this
one like I'm not interested really no
I'm gonna eat it that's the point of the
taste test my friend I don't like this
this is like surprises you don't like
surprises
[Music]
you wanna try I mean I guess oh I think
I do not like um I've heard that this
isn't right
this is crazy I prayed you better try
but I want I want a ton of new fruits
this is exciting it's a little bit pear
like I can admit but it's a little
thicker than a pear it's usually tasty
it's you Jerry like creamy yeah there's
a tang
this is the worst way of saying it but
like a meatiness to it that's not about
what I say at all yeah it's a good way
to said maybe we'll let this one get
there I'll take this one me too it's
cute yeah I'd buy it what what how much
money you're just buying Jane she said
would you buy it from the store I am NOT
going out of my way to buy this okay
yeah I'm gonna have a fruit moment I'm a
pretty standard and what I like you know
I don't try a lot of new things I was
really nervous for this video but I like
these this is all controlled I think I
would try this next time I would tend to
ten eat all these fruits again and I
want to discover even more fruits I'm
like excited that there are still fruits
that I have not yet tasted those are not
my choice to buy but now I kind of want
to buy because it's pretty it's like
yeah freakin tasty if you're really
gonna go this story and you have all
these options here's what you do this is
fun for a second not that good sell it
this is exciting on the outside not that
cool on the inside this grab a bunch
grab I don't know what a collection of
dragon fruit is called
a gaggle of dragons oh yes a dragon grab
a drag Allah dragon fruits because these
things are worth it
[Music]